there's a new news channel in the uk i'm
andrew neal
and this is gb news
some critics are calling it the fox news
of britain
although that comparison seems a tad
over exaggerated
when you think of poverty you picture
this but what if i told you
it really looks like this and by the way
for all you kids watching at home
santa just is white but this person is
just arguing that
that maybe we should we should also have
a black santa and we don't care about
dead babies screw
you you might think it's beneficial that
a part of the population's views
are finally being reflected in an open
and
pluralistic media landscape don't be
silly
of course there is already a mission to
cancel
gb news in fact it started before the
channel even launched
no what a joy gb news is aiming to be
patriotic and not london-centric
and to open up debate in a country where
much of the media doesn't actually
reflect the views
of much of the people he's quite fraught
as you can imagine yeah
gb news isn't big on subtlety and is
going
group one it has a segment called
wokewatch
which ironically has enraged the cancel
culture mob
guys that's the point and the group stop
funding hate again blind to the irony
hates right-of-center views and tries to
cancel
any media outlet that expresses them and
with some success this time
it's managing to get advertisers to pull
their ads from the channel
for some reason swedes are leading this
boycott
swedish copperberg cider has said that
it wasn't aware that it was on the
channel
and that it will be pulling its ads
because it wants to be
inclusive there's that irony again
others in the boycott
include beer brand gross the open
university
and nivea and a bunch of others have
said that they're going to review that
advertising
on gb news sort of woke fence sitters
cancel culture will eat itself though
in response to the woke advertising
boycott copperbag cider
is facing its own boycott by
mathematically challenged viewers of gb
news
dear at copperberg uk i've bought my
daughter
four bottles a week for a good while now
that's 250 plus bottles a year
no longer purchased so advertisers
boycotting the news channel
and fans of the news channel boycotting
the advertisers
for cancelling their ads the woke mob
versus the conservative mob
and if you're wondering what this lack
of tolerance looks like
in real life here's the political editor
of the bbc's news night being mobbed
by conservative anti-lockdown protesters
who disagree
with the bbc's reporting
why can't we all just get along